TONIGHT THE FISH IS A DEANNA
WORK AND READ ANDERSON.THE
MONTREAL ZONE.
THERE OUT OF THERE.
WE'RE
>> Tripp: THEY TOOK ADVANTAGE
TELUS
TRADERS, RECIPES.E OF THE
THREE STARS.
MONTREALCENTER ICE.JORDAN
STAAL.
YOU NEVER KNOW.THIS COULD BE SI
PLATTER TIME.
POINT.
THE POWER PLAY RECENTLY AGAINST
DETROIT.
MONTREAL, HAS A PUCK IN THE
HURRICANE ZONE.VE IT,
WHY WOULDN'T THEY?
THE LOCOMOTIVE,
ABOUT A 90 FOOTE PASS.  BOTH SP
THERE IS ANAN
THE PUCK COMES BACK TO A POINT.
PENALTY COMING UP  AGAINST
MONTREAL.
MONTEMBEAULT, DENIES GAMES.
ANOTHER SHOT SLAVIN, MADE EIGHT
TAKE THE
>> Referee: CAROLINA,
D'ANGELO,
BY TER
ACROSS.LL GET THE
EN HAS A POWER
PLAY GOAL, IN THE SAME GAME  IN
HIS CAREER IN ATELY, IT STARTED
WITH
>>.
>> Mike: BEMADE A
REALLY GOOD DECISION.
YOU DO NOT
IT GOES OFF TARGET..OING TO GET
GORGEOUS FINISH GOING AGAINST
THE GRAIN, AS FRONT
FOR AHO.